we're going to begin with this it's
going to be another frantic day in
washington this morning with president
biden's domestic agenda facing new
pushback from his own party
but we need to begin on capitol hill
where there will be new testimony about
the president's decision to withdraw
from afghanistan military leaders told
the senate armed services committee
yesterday they did advise the president
to keep some troops in that country now
that contradicts president biden's
version of the events officials also
painted a very dark picture of the
future of afghanistan chris van cleave
joins us from capitol hill where another
round of testimony is expected today i
watched part of it yesterday chris it
got very heated good morning to you
good morning we expect that grilling to
continue this time on the house side
with more heated exchanges with
republicans including calls for the
generals to resign now this was the
first time we had heard from the
nation's top military officials since
the august 31st withdrawal and the death
of those 13 service members
and at points the generals broke with
the president
i recommended that we maintain 2500
troops in afghanistan
in a nearly six-hour hearing the
nation's top military leaders publicly
contradicted president biden telling
lawmakers they told the
commander-in-chief to maintain a
military presence in afghanistan my
assessment was
back in the fall of 20 and remain
consistent throughout that we should
keep a steady state of 2500 and it could
bounce up to 3 500. did these officer
and general miller's recommendations get
to the president personally their input
was uh
was received by the president and
considered by the president but in a
recent tv interview mr biden denied that
no no one said that to me that i can
recall chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general mark milley defended the
u.s withdrawal but admitted it was a
logistical success but a strategic
failure while the pentagon brass
acknowledged intelligence saying the
afghan government would likely fall they
did not expect it to happen so fast we
certainly did not plan against a
collapse of a government in 11 days the
witnesses also broke with president
biden over this statement my fellow
americans
the war in afghanistan is now over
the war in terror is not over and the
war in afghanistan is not over either in
another major moment of the hearing
general milley acknowledged being a
source to several high-profile
journalists writing books about former
president trump and addressed reports he
called his chinese counterpart in the
final days of the trump presidency to
assure him an attack was not imminent
these military-to-military
communications at the highest level are
critical to the security of the united
states in order to de-conflict military
actions manage crisis and present
prevent war between great powers that
are armed with the world's most
deadliest weapons
now the white house is defending the
president saying recommendations from
his military advisers were split on
troop levels and that ultimately it is
the commander-in-chief's decision
something the generals yesterday said
they agree with they also reiterated
they felt that the president heard their
feedback now general milley also warned
that al qaeda could gain strength under
the taliban and pose a threat to the
united states in as little as 12 months
nate
chris thank you so much